[Music]
[Applause]
and
I'm rowing ocean so far with
crossings I've made I'm
building six world records like
that most people don't but I keep
myself must have open fans the
antiquity that the first so one notice
also omnipotent are oceans and you again
things can be done about this
yes this is the last kiev god or
pick up everything but when i am with a long
country i still have bosoms of yes you
have to leave
i will of course immediately cross
my ocean for the seventh time  how to get an iron
team in the bottom 6 people
there is a huge this heap
in addition I have two swedes on board
and we have nose but along the way
you don't feel any limits I'm completely
fine you actually all shelagh and
then you have to work through it too  and
that is of course also with the climate
of the future
we actually all come from
different countries with different
rules but in the end you will
also have everyone with the same
rules worldwide  have to cooperate a bit to of
course achieve cleaner
climates and get fewer
emissions in less pollution
you have a little bit with style chelsea
talking about how I am at it would be
easy to see that you really see in the middle of
the ocean companies there stars that
really like  us really one of the most
things
and if it's a bit of tour
thinking fishing were also from rey nice
i know that keeps it all inside
on the ice cream death of
very bad plastic soup some very slowly
breast
we make the cat one first  good
steps in europe kitchen is of course
very nice that we believe in weeks very much
the one hour a europe that is also
started eventually
to preserve safety and freedom we
have come a long way but also
to be in the same mood in how you
approach the environment
[Music  ]
ocean rowing sometimes do
n't make it with climate change
workers have to do things we also
have to help with some more investments
tower c staff do more  ear
[Music]